any apologies
appear to be none conflicts of interest
appear to be none confirmation of
minutes are there any corrections to the
minutes
for someone prepared to move the
adoption of the minutes moved by jason
seconded sarah i'll put that all those
in favor please say aye
contrary carried matters arising just
one issue uh on on the quarry we don't
need to record it if you like
um
here to say we're making good progress
with with him and all the issues are in
hand as far as we're concerned at this
stage
as far as the quarry goes just so you're
aware of that
anything any other matters arising
it appears to be nuts
there's robbie entering the red light
district
right no deputations presentations no
adjourned business the first report
on milton reserve pages 20 to
29 grant welcome
basically it's just a carry-on from the
workshop
very brief update
they did say that they would obviously
have preferred that large area that went
under the trees
um but they were they were happy to find
that that was
that there was at least this piece here
and then
during the consultation and put that out
to their members to
see what their members felt as a wider
collective rather than just as
the small group development but so that
was good good from them
the monorail railway people
we had a bit of a discussion around what
it would mean to be
located and get that spot and
that there's obviously at least four
traffic going past
black street
i consider those things um
they did suggest as you see the reporter
suggested
alternative locations of the uh the old
bunnings building
but it was probably less likely that
milton to proceed so
you got pretty supportive of that um so
as you can see it hasn't changed
i guess the overall design uh altogether
that much the concept has stayed the
same we've just got the addition of that
uh slight change to this right it's
going to agility area
and there's also identified off here
the toilets which are scheduled for
23-24
approval for um or taken down to
consultations
think about that as part of that we
would be approaching uh
just to work through any specifications
they might have
not only about to stop that but at that
area or stop back
which is that kind of secondary flow
so we're here we will be having
so
all the services associated with the
ability and things
um
and so that's obviously over over the
workshop around that being a potential
project between more
town x which is project particular
landscape budget so
we have recommended
towards this as a town insurance
development
through there which you've got enough
budget to do that should you wish
um and you've done 561
since the writing of this report um
we've also been approached it's not
really linked to
milton apart from being sort of close
but we're we're being
approached by the accessibility group
around
a question around whether the board
might be interested in using the
landscape and budget also to put a seat
in down
by the arlington shopping center
we activate whether they want the budget
for general landscaping
to do that so this seat generally costs
about two and a half
grand to put it the reason i'm bringing
it up
is because we're currently considering
allocating money towards regionality
approaching so it's good if you have
that in your mind
um
myself during lockdown spent a lot of
time walking around that
the area and noticed a bit of a lack of
seating so i could i could
empathize with the groups
just on the arlington the issue
came up uh chris greengrass the
president of
the chair of caipore community board is
chair of the access
group and she was approached by the
rangiora group
that there is no seating anywhere or
anywhere they can sit down if they go to
the
arlington shopping center raised it with
me i
raised it with the staff and looking
at this well it's a backdoor approach
uh we could add it on to
either e tonight or or if in one form
another if the board were of a
mine too um was it
i thought i thought the cost would be up
up to 2000 do you think it would be more
than that
um
thank you poor question
development
so there's a big chunk of your budget um
um you would have budget next year to
spend um
in terms of town entrances the line
sideway
road one uh all up that's come to
i think just shy of 40 000.
entrance that's around europe there's a
flight with that kind of spending
it doesn't leave you 35 000 feeling
sorry thanks for having me
[Music]
around the light-side interest and she
believes that
that the work will be done without
further
ado that's all part of because they're
just waiting for it
so we maybe expected something for
capping burger avenue um around the 35
to 40k as well coming up then if the
other
entrances of that sort of cost
so i should use this um expectation is a
strong word i i guess
the the board have have previously
signaled and working on developing those
town entrance so in terms of what this
budget goes towards it is entirely your
decision and this
no one can put expectations that you you
have to spend on town entrances but
if you're looking at developing that
entrance it likely is going to be
somewhere
in that realm um i know there was
previous plans
done for kirbenberger which were well
and truly above that realm
um but it all depends on what you choose
to do down there so
it wouldn't be out of line to think that
at some point if you want to continue
with the town interests yes
that would be good we have no knowledge
of what what the final analysis will be
on kippenberger and by that stage we'll
have another grant in next year's
budgets
yeah kirsten yes i was just going to ask
no
um excuse me point of order i hadn't
finished your question i said that was
the first question
well i'll come i'll come back to you i
don't always give members
continuous questions i like to move it
around but i i thought you had finished
i apologize for that but
kirsten started so we'll come back to
you paul
um just liz i thought we'd already
repeat received a report at
council that due to the potential for
development in the kippenberger area
that
that was going to be on hold until the
development was sorted
you've got a loud
there has been some previous
conversation around kippenberger because
of some of the
challenges that that area had posed
particularly around the
trees and it's been previously discussed
so
yeah there is no my understanding is
there's no intention to bring that back
to life at this stage no that's correct
paul williams um second question i've
got two more after this
kevin i've got two more questions after
this
um the toilet the sewer is that going to
be connected to the actual main sewer
line that goes down river road or
you're looking at septic tank system for
it
i believe that would be into the sewer
so there's already
toilets in the croquet tail bowls cup
so i haven't done a detailed analysis of
exactly where those pipes are but
we would anticipate that they should go
to that connection
that's cool um and seats what budget do
they normally come out of when you put
seats around
reserves is that normally a landscaping
out of the community boards
it all depends really if we have budget
to develop so sometimes we'll have a
specific budget to develop a reserve
um for example which i think
um
part of that development we've got
seating and things to work with that
in terms of this sort of situation where
it's like i guess a standalone
item it generally is
if it's coming from green spaces
generally yet
yes so that there's no other budget you
can take it from
cool and last question can i have a
breakdown please that 165 000 for the
fencing and
what have you my memory isn't that good
off hand at the moment
but i have an idea couldn't you come
back to us on that
brilliant thank you kirsten
thank you for all the information grant
it looks like um you've done a lot of
work on this plan
the question i've got is i know the
model railway club has some funding
available i know the dog parker
fundraising but what about the arboretum
where's the fund
funds for the actual arboretum coming
from what is the intention
you're hard to hear thank you um
so i guess that's a vision which has
been put by trevor
to council as a use for that space um
and to the board
he he hasn't got funding behind him to
actually do that it's more
look this is what i believe would be a
great use
in terms of from our green space point
of view we love trees
um we also see there's
the ability to plant
trees especially large specimen ones um
in towns especially sort of
closer in um gets limited more and more
um especially with the impacts of
shading and things even even in some of
our
established reserves we get we're
constantly getting people asking to chop
um trees down which is shading them and
things so
an opportunity to plant trees in
a reserve like this and create that is
one that we felt was worth exploring
and so yeah the the budget would come it
so
part of the breakdown that i'll be
providing will be showing that part of
that is actually paying for the
establishment of those so that's out of
that current militant reserve budget but
will you we'll start be asking for more
than that budget for the arboretum
uh so that not apart from the
the allocation of general landscaping
budget that we believe we can achieve
this with that
that budget yeah thank you thank you any
other questions
jason um firstly thank you for your time
uh just a quick question with regards to
the model club
is there much risk of 10 15 years down
the track another club
coming along and requesting a bit of
land in the reserve or do we have
are we at the risk of setting a
precedent for it
i i guess um you're only at risk of
setting precedence as to how much the
community board accepts precedence
so um if another club comes
and wants to go there then the
application would be
treated by the community board who are
then at that stage um and and should be
i i guess there's a little bit of you
can't say
well sorry we're not letting anyone in
there because you have already but that
being said
we've already that reserve already has
the croquet table bowls
um club they're established there anyway
so um
yeah i think i don't don't know that
you're adding precedent
by by allowing them to be there thank
you
yes liz just sorry clarify my
understanding so you
mentioned about the seat um
kind of like as a oh and
um and obviously the board doesn't have
point is it your intention to bring some
more information back to the board
at a later stage or will we be looking
at changing
the recommendation today i i'm proposing
in a moment to move a recommendation to
include that liz
yeah thank you
because they're considering managing
landscaping budget allocation they can
choose to allocate it towards that we
just
call the general landscaping budget
resolution
further questions duncan
grant and then monique it's regarding
the the
section of ekin land at the top end um
from a landscaping perspective you would
always take consideration of
of shading regarding road safety in line
of sight because
at the moment it looks a perfect line of
sight but you could argue that if people
obey their own rules and read the signs
it should be as safe as anything but
you'd be watching what you planted in
the top end is what i'm asking
yeah certainly and and i guess um
also to note would be with with um
generally speaking and actually trees
were in most of our reserves we
we do work with the trees and limb them
up so you can see underneath and things
so
um yeah i don't anticipate that that
would be
a major concern here monique
i'm just going to ask about the
plantings um
i showed them keep bringing you a
beautiful grape the
plain of trevors and they were concerned
about the planting
not being suitable in that area could
they be invited to perhaps
be involved in what is planted there
yeah absolutely yeah in terms of the
tree
species that are going to go on there
we're going to need to
um make sure that we're quite careful in
terms of what goes in there it won't be
i think trevor has a vision of a lot of
exotic and a lot of um
specific trees um some of those like
i've had look fruitless a lot of those
would
survive down there but there's some that
we without i guess
the knowledge of our green space team
would go we've tried those around this
area we probably won't go there
um it's a case by case of actually
you're doing a bit of research and
and keeping your beautiful would be a
great group to have involved in that
because they've also got that local
knowledge so
yeah i don't know if they're interested
but
i know grant you're going to discuss
species with environment canterbury's
engineers
what experience do they have on tree
species
they're pretty good at taking them down
in that area but
so it wouldn't be just species that
we're discussing with them it would be
um placement um in in terms of whether
there's a certain amount of trees in
there that they wouldn't want over or
anything like that um
it would be it would be tree species in
terms of some trees
um they don't like anywhere near
waterways because they're more prolific
and spreading
um or they have issues with some trees
pretty much
um i won't go into all the different
ones they have but um there's some trees
that they really specifically don't like
in there so we would take that into
account all of that
information um because we're doing it as
part of the consultation process that
information would come
back to the board um and there's an
explanation for
any decisions that we made around that
plan
any further questions we need your
microphone
thank you all right well i'll test the
meeting i'll move
a b c
d e if
if one approves the allocation of the 35
thousand
budget and two if
two approved staff uh spending up to two
thousand dollars in arlington shopping
center area for suitable seats
seating and g will change to
this will leave eleven thousand five
hundred and sixty one dollars
in the budget have i seconded for that
segment by duncan
it it seems really pleasing i think that
at last milton's getting out
again in a more final state because it's
been in front of this board for a long
long time
forget how long murray but it'd be four
or five years at least i should think
so that making progress trevor wright's
rung me he's delighted
because he won't necessarily agree with
the type of trees that planted there
but he's delighted it's making progress
and you have been
consulting him i've already mentioned
that seat it seems
sensible to put that there while we've
got an opportunity with a
slide it in on a motion almost
not quite illegally but um it qualifies
under that so and it's it's good that
uh we're addressing the other issues
besides the
beautification long term of that area
with the model railway club as well
as the dog park and so that'll be a
stunning area in time
the dog park there's recognized people
tell me it's as good a dog park as there
is
anywhere in new zealand so this will
even enhance it
a little bit a little bit more so i have
no problem moving this recommendation
duncan
well i have very little to add other
than echo what you've just said but i
think from a board's perspective
and especially the new members on the
board um here's the great opportunity to
endorse this
because i think if you look back when i
look back on my time
within council you know time goes by but
here's an opportunity to say well i was
part of this or i
recommend it i think it is a great move
forward
and it tidies up a long issue that's
been outstanding for a large
period of time and we can make it happen
it'll be great
kirsten i guess this is a major entrance
way in
into rangiora and it has always looked a
bit sad with the pine trees as much as
it's got a natural look
um it would be nice to make that look a
bit more pleasant for people coming in
um the groups that are in there are very
proactive
and the dog park people have raised lots
of money for
the dog park they've had community
buy-in um
so it's building on something that's
already working well
the model railway club have to move out
of the building
in blake street and you can see with the
shortage of parking and rang uruguay
because that area we're going to have to
do something about it at some point
and it's getting more and more urgent so
they will then be homeless
and they are a very very keen club
and they're also educating young people
in those skills as well
and bringing a lot of joy to the
children in our district so
them having a base will further their
ambitions in that area
the arboretum is an absolutely
outstanding
idea um i'm very pleased that it's come
from a member of the community as a
vision
i'm obviously just a little cautious
about the type of trees like everyone
has mentioned
and also the budget because it does
we are going to be really tight over the
next three years and so there won't be
very much to give for extra initiatives
however money sticks to a good idea and
i've no doubt that
the community gets behind it and can see
the vision that's put into the plan
and that will get some really good
feedback on this consultation
paul yeah i think it'd be a good thing
to
proceed and and happen it's uh
needed area cleaning up the only
apprehension i've got is
the um um
when would you have to do um kingsbury
avenue
one day we may need a budget for that
and we may be stretched to get enough
for that but um
we'll cross that bridge when it when it
happens um
but um the model railway club year
that's very important they're a good
group and they go to the school holidays
the our own library and get a lot of
support so um
and i think there will be a good place
for them to um
to do their bits and pieces there's
nowhere else for them in ranger at this
stage so
that's really good so be good to see
that area really tidied up
and um yeah and that's about um
all i i would actually like to wonder
about the seat
whether before we actually spend it
although
it can be in the budget whether we could
actually approach a
um good group like the lions club or
rotary to see whether
they wanted to um help towards donate a
seat for that area with the
um the things that good things they do
around the community that may
help our budget but apart from it really
good
thank you anybody else
all right there's nothing to reply to so
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
the contrary carried item 6.2
pages 30-39
joanne
thank you this
report is seeking approval to change two
raised pedestrian platforms within
rangiora town centre
one on percival street outside the
courthouse
and the other one on victoria street 2
pedestrian crossings
we have reviewed sorry we've carried out
a review
due to comments that were raised service
requests and also letters
that had come in relating to not only
these raised platforms but also
other crossings within the district we
circulated a memo to the board in
october
around courtesy crossings and since then
we've also carried out a review
and pedestrian counts in these two
locations
so during a one hour period on the
percival street
crossing we had a count of 144
pedestrians
and on victoria street we had a count of
106.
we require a minimum pedestrian number
of
at least 50 for a pedestrian crossing to
be considered
i just note in the recommendations um
the cost
of changing these two pedestrian
erase platforms to pedestrian crossings
is around two and a half half thousand
dollars for
signs and road marking but do need to
note
that that does not include lighting of
the pedestrian crossings
um i would also note that rang euro
towns centre the high street
crossings do not have lighting currently
that's compliant with the standard
and this would be something that we
would be looking to address
as part of a future lighting upgrade
along the street
i'm happy to take any questions right
any questions to join
kirsten joanne
um comfortable with the
victoria street one but with the pers
full street one it's got very poor
visibility
at the moment with those raised
platforms and so people are very
cautious they stop
and look and make eye contact with the
parked cars coming out
such a long way um
with the thought that we have heard that
more people are killed on pedestrian
crossings sometimes than
courtesy do you perceive any other
changes that could be made to that area
to improve the visibility
and give um cars and pedestrians ideas
of who has the right of way
there because at the moment even cars
are having trouble getting through there
with the narrow parking
yep we do get the odd comments regarding
the parking and we've also got angle
parking along the eastern side of
percival street outside the farmer's
building
and around about two or three parallel
parks on the western side
now the comments that we normally get
are i have to wait
and it takes time to get through the
area but to be honest that's a good
thing
because it actually slows traffic down
so what we do find is when there aren't
cars parked in there
that we get an increase of speed of
vehicles going through that area which
is
actually more of an issue from a safety
perspective
in terms of increasing visibility
to be honest i don't think there would
be a lot that could be done
and i think really that's around we've
got the planter boxes with the street
trees
on the eastern side of the road
and we obviously wouldn't want to be
touching those
apart from taking car parking out which
is probably not
highly desirable in the town centre you
know i think it would probably be
limited that we could do at some point
members raised the idea of having
uh stop making sure it's clear type sign
at the midi string crossing had any more
thought being given
to that in that um in the town centre
area
yep so we attached to that report as the
memo that came out to the board um in
october
and after reviewing so with
with courtesy crossings they are they
require courtesy
from both both parties they require the
driver to be courteous
and they require the pedestrian to make
eye contact and actually
for the two to come to some agreement as
to who's going to go
um we as i said we've had a number of
service requests
where there definitely is confusion
around
who has the right of way which is partly
an education thing which we are planning
on doing um some education when we roll
out some stencil
marking that we're going to look at at
some of the raised platforms
um and what we had planned
is basically marked on the footpath
uh check before you step painted stamp
um that is an option for us to
consider in the town centre in these two
locations
if the board didn't want to move to a
pedestrian crossing
um again it relies on people
making reading making those decisions
and
and stepping out accordingly it's
it's a really challenging one and it
becomes a risk-based
argument we do see people stepping out
onto courtesy crossings on a regular
basis and not
necessarily understanding that they
don't have the right of way
paul and then jason have you had any
recorded
accidents happening on these two
pedestrian cross or you know
um crossings at the moment i'm not aware
of indian rangura i
am aware of one i think in kaiapoi
on williams street yeah
they are normally relatively low speed
environments
and to be honest some of it is people
will get a big fright
and they we will then end up with a
serious request or a complaint because
it's given them such fright
jason um thank you for the report i
actually quite enjoyed reading this one
um i noticed that um victoria street
included people
crossing in the subway winnebago section
i was just wondering
how many of them would have been
crossing there and
would there be anything i know it would
be frustrating because of infrastructure
would there be any consideration to
actually move the crossing to the south
side
of albert street as opposed to maintain
it where it is
yeah look that's a really good question
um i don't have the exact number in
front of me
um and i think the numbers on the
northern side of the road were slightly
higher than
the ones at winnibago's but there will
be a desire line
um for people who are wanting to go to
subway or to winnie bae goes there
victoria street is a little bit more
challenging we could
look at something like
a wider tabletop or raised platform in
the longer term there
but if
the the issue with that one is if you
make people walk three legs
to get to the same place then they're
unlikely to do it
they'll just take the shortest route
which is why we haven't recommended
closing that
crossing point outside subway cool thank
you
any other questions have a
paul right here
um i think it's a sensible thing to do
because at the moment there's hesitation
and people don't know whether
they've got the right of way and or
actually um
i know you know i've seen people myself
they've sort of um
start crossing the air and some cars
want to give away some don't
so it just takes that um
you know the uh information and the
correct way of doing it so
i think it's a good move
robbie
what about your speaker is it all right
i would have concerned some of the other
courtesy
crossings
is
but again at the moment it seems to be
working okay these two things where they
are
um as i say i have questions they're
getting answers on their faces
and i appreciated you copying me into
your correspondence thanks robbie
any other speakers of course you may
just um with regards to the notice the
check before you step
i'm curious is it is um for younger
kid younger people children etc are they
better to have words or symbols
to remind them to look you know like a
pair of eyes looking at them or
something or something to
you know what is more effective with
younger people
to remind them to look for traffic and
i'm just curious whether they'll read
check before you step where's the symbol
maybe more effective
yeah and and i unders i do understand
where you're coming from with that and
it
will be possibly challenging to try and
pictorially
get that across to a younger child
technically children should be
supervised when they are out and about
in
a busy town centre and
i guess that would be our expectation
i think it would be challenging to try
and have
words and pictures and not end up with
something that's quite
cluttered and maybe a little unsightly
kirsten well i'm prepared to support the
motion i'm very very
concerned about the one on percival
street it's straight outside the library
and i've seen children run straight from
the library to that crossing
if they think that it's safe to go
straight across as a pedestrian crossing
and they may not continue and the
visibility is quite poor for drivers
it's quite hard to see them past the
planters
when they're little and past the parked
cars
that one i think needs some major
education it needs a major campaign of
some sort to say this has changed
this is what you have to do also perhaps
involving the local schools who do
come to the library quite regularly even
to just educate them on that
pedestrian crossings are not for you to
walk straight across because a driver
may not have seen you
in any other speakers there's nothing to
reply to so i'll put that all those in
favor please say aye
the country carried thank you joanne
just before you go
um i was asked today what's happening
with the
lights on the trees they've been all off
again
christmas is coming are they going to be
working properly uh i believe so so
we've got some plans in place
and we will get them checked uh on a
daily basis as we roll into
into christmas just to make sure that
they are i'm also where there's a timer
issue at the moment between the two
controllers so i think one was coming on
earlier than the other
um but yeah we've got that okay in hand
thank
thank you jane item 6.3 pages 40 to 49
road naming k
good evening everyone um unfortunately
scott couldn't make the meeting tonight
so um you'll have to put up with yours
truly
um the goldie drive one
as you probably aware already is on one
side of the road
so that's just an extension down
which i would imagine the board wouldn't
bother much about and the other is
oakville close
so i presume i'll take that as read and
uh
hopefully none of you will have any
questions
prove her wrong any questions
paul are young people that live on
goldie drive
all right we have a recommendation seems
straightforward
yep purely because i understand there
are a couple of artists
names on offer to go in those places
or goldie but there's also there are um
you know are there other streets in that
neighborhood that might be able to have
those artists names and future but
perhaps you won't know that sorry
well the other ones are townsend road
and pentecost road so no they
they mentioned vinnie and gibb were two
other names that were mentioned as being
possibilities
that were there were artists
and the other question was goldie um
when they extend it
how are the numbers you probably don't
know that either i'm sorry
do people have to change their num their
num plot numbers on their mailboxes
or they're just going to go i presume
it's around the correct way
um in the reporter they talk about
starting the numbering from pentecost
so i presume the top end was numbered
correctly
at the time that they were
built all right i presume does carry on
that's all right that'll do right
someone prepared to move something
jason
so you're moving the recommendation and
do you wish to speak to it
duncan
clearly outlines the reasons why
all right i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
contrary carried item 6.4 pages 50 to
80.
um application for the discretionary
grant k
um this is a another
toy library i think we've had toy
library once or twice before
the popular triangle sounds very very
ambitious for a little wooden climbing
frame
but i'll take the reporters read
and um i couldn't find any particular
reason
why the board wouldn't want to um
to help with that any questions
they're asking for 494 some people moves
something andy's yeah
andy's moved i'll just come back to you
in a minute paul
no no it's been moved every second and
then i'll come back for the question
a second by money question
you thought the questions before the
moving well
i'd ask for more questions no one asked
any i asked remover and the mover had
moved
so it was appropriate to finish that and
then come back to you
we're not denying you your question yeah
um just the
last meeting the chairman um of our
group was sort of suggesting that
this these grants were set up for people
um for businesses or
uh organizations as a first type thing
to get them moving and what have you
and um and not keep repeating requests
for
bits and pieces all these size i was
going to ask the um
chairman to sort of um um
uh his opinion on what he was saying
last meeting
compared with what happened i'm saying
very much what you have enunciated
normally an application
we don't normally make it an annual
event for them
to come annually back and that would
then be appropriate to go to the council
for permanent funding
if that's what they were wanting and so
there's nothing wrong with making one or
two grants but not on a permanent basis
that's what they're saying yes okay
if you have a look at the criteria of
the funding it does say that a group may
actually
apply twice a year as long as it doesn't
exceed 500.
um this group is only
applied periodically it hasn't applied
every year
no no jason duncan
oh no sorry it was paul
and monique
andy monique we get there eventually
right did anyone else wish to speak
andy do you wish to speak to it
uh you so well thank you mr chuman
um my perception of the tour library is
that it's particularly beneficial
to probably our lower socioeconomic
families that can't afford to go and buy
all of these things for themselves
and you know we have a reasonable amount
of money in
our budget still for this so i think
it's a fantastic course
monique
robbie and then kirsten
um some of you may be aware that there's
a
fees and charges working party
with regard to groups that use
community facilities
i'm on it uh this this term
and we've received around about 60 to 70
applications
for a reduction in what we charge people
for using council facilities
what i have been indicating is that some
of these groups instead of going through
the community and recreation team
should in fact be looking at their local
boards
with regard to seeking money
to date there's only been a couple that
we have not
approved to a degree so there's a degree
of
still subsidizing these really great
causes
however at this stage we're still over
forty thousand dollars
as far as what we have let these groups
off the normal rate
so i would hope that the boards can
expect
to see in the future some applications
from some of these very good causes
with regard to utilising
our facilities thanks robbie
i think it's really really important to
remember the groups that apply to us
are all pretty much run by volunteers
and they service the sector of the
community that
we can't necessarily look after so they
actually give us incredible value for
money
we've always maintained in this grant
system it's only a small grant it's only
five hundred dollars
and that it's on a project basis so we
don't want groups to apply for
operational funding
absolutely agree but we do want them to
apply if they need to buy more assets or
they need to have
some sort of activity that's different
from their general day-to-day
administration
so i have absolutely no problem with
groups applying twice a year
and that's basically as you said in our
criteria
i've got a different view from robbie on
the fees and charges
i actually feel horribly uncomfortable
if groups come to us
asking for money to pay back council
fees
it's like paying money to yourself so
it's a round circle thing
i think the appropriate place for them
to come is to the community facilities
fees and charges working group to prove
that financially
they're not able to operate successfully
as a community group
non-profit under the current fees regime
and so i would prefer us to be very
open-minded with some of these groups
some of these groups may come back every
year some don't we try to encourage as
many groups
as we possibly can to apply for these
little bits of help
that just get them over the line on some
of their projects i will remind you that
most years
we are undersubscribed we actually have
money left over
at the end of the year so um i i think
we can afford to be a little bit
generous
in this space i think we can afford to
spread the money around
nice and equally um but i don't like
paying council money
back to council i think you make a very
valid point i think we always have money
left over at the end of
this nearly always i can only remember
back in the pool days that we
didn't
right anyone else to speak
okay there's nothing andy to reply
paul did you want to speak
i am um need to really point out make
sure everybody realizes
normally a grants is going towards a wee
bit of a hardship group
this group's actually got 42 000 in
their bank
and credit an actual cash so um
i just personally don't seem to think
that's quite a
a bit of a hardship bit of a grant which
normally we try to
um point of order mr chair is hardship
one of our criteria
no no it's not points of order but
no no no i'm speaking at the moment but
he's
quite entitled to raise the question
he's debating it and he's quite within
standing orders to make the point he's
making
thank you that's all i need okay
all right no further debate i'll put
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye
country carried 6.5
meeting workshop dates okay
um as per usual this comes up at the end
of every
year for you to resolve on your meeting
dates for
the following year um as you will have
noticed i
said that we are going to be here until
the council chamber
is available so i don't know how long
that will take
um but the meeting dates basically
follow the same
pattern as the last year
second wednesday so it's the second
wednesday of of the month
currently at 7 00 pm unless members
have a sudden surge of energy
and change it to six or eight
i'll take any questions
[Laughter]
no one's got a sudden urge of energy
here
right we've got to recommend any
questions okay someone prepared to move
the recommendation move by sarah ii
monique do you wish to speak to
syria
all right anyone else all right i'll put
that all those in favor
please say the country carried
item 8 the cheers report i'll move its
adoption duncan seconds that
all those in favor please say hey
question yes certainly
i just wanted to know the outcome of the
meeting with the cast equestrian club
have you got any update on that
no
green space here i think it was all
positive
that was my interpretation of the
meeting yeah
thank you all those in favor please say
aye to the contrary carried
item nine uh matters for
your information we need to
receive there to someone prepared to
move the ring jason move
segmented by andy put that all those in
favor please say all right
country carried um we'll start
we'll start with you robbie
thank you so heaps and heaps of uh of
briefings obviously with
an ltp coming up and issues around three
waters
um we've got roading and drainage
as well so yeah lots and lots of
briefings we had a meeting with the
salon district council
a couple of weeks ago which i quite
enjoyed actually it was
it was a good couple of hours touching
on
issues that we have in common
probably of of more interest to the
group and i'm sorry i'm not going to be
able to give you much information
other than what i'm getting from my
niece myself at the moment with regard
to the
yellow bin audits there are some
addresses
that have had their second occasion
where they have failed to have the
correct material in their recycling bin
and a third strike and you're out you're
losing your bin
so apparently a few have been getting a
little bit
heated in their exchanges with uh with
manis
um but it's it's something that um
as i say the more information will come
out in
in due course but
needless to say it's disappointing
because it only takes one contaminated
bin to contaminate the truck
and then the truck's contaminated it
goes to cape valley and we're all paying
for that
extra so um
you know but i just can't understand how
people are not
getting it i really am struggling with
it
but so that's it from me jim robbie
when they get their warning are they
spoken to or is it
just something on the bin i can
understand on the benefits
denise has been following up as best she
can yeah
to say look you cannot put
that material this material into that
bin it's got to go
into your red bin or alternatively um
if you know potentially goes into your
your green bin
you know it's your chicken bones now i
put crayfish bodies into my green bin
the
first dive of the season you know so
there's a lot of things that would have
gone in
into the red bin that you can actually
put into your green bin because it all
gets munched up
so um and people just not getting it
it's actually quite strange putting chop
bones and chicken bones and things into
your green waste i must
duncan you had a question to robbie
robbie
i thought kitty had made a very good
press release
because she came to this meeting one or
two meetings ago
and the press release that was released
afterwards regarding outlining clearly
what it was
costing the council um it was very clear
and
there's a point that this man was trying
to make the kitty if she published the
issue of
just how many thousand dollars it was
costing waimak district to dump it
um perhaps something would get through
to people
i'm one of the offenders i'm sorry to
admit so i'll tell you how it goes
i did actually i got a thing no i did
genuinely made a mistake um yes
so receipts no a receipt was in the box
and yes so they were and also some
plastic that
would have not been there but they were
very good it was great little note they
put a note in my mailbox
plus their offending matter and um it
was and they
listed what the problems were so i
thought they did a very good service and
i won't be offending again
there's a very honest member of the
board
[Laughter]
all right kirsten sorry just just to
make it critically clear
you're a good person your bin was almost
right
okay so if you've got a note in your
letterbox with staff you are a good
person okay
this is the message it's got wrong i'm
afraid and unfortunately it's a message
we need to get rid
if you've got a wee bit of contamination
they put a little bit and say hey
don't do this next time but they collect
your bin if they collect your boom
you've done fine
if they leave your bin there and put a
big nasty note on the leather book on
that thing and then my niece follows up
then you're in trouble
so what the message that's gone out the
community is you're bad
if you get stuck in the letterbox it's
you're not it's an education exercise
so we need to spread the word and say if
you've been got collected you're doing
fine
you just need to tidy up a couple of
things maybe and and that's what this
whole process is about
you're not going to get your bin taken
away for having a couple of bits of
bicycles and reception
thank you so much you don't need to
stand in the corner after all
robbie you're done great kirsten
um yes i keep forgetting what month
rooms
um apologies mr chair um district plan
briefings are my key focus we're really
heavily into extra briefings for
district plan
we're covering the entire e-plan um
which once it's
once the draft has gone through it will
then come out for people to be able to
actually look at it all
online which will be really exciting and
that's due for completion around about
february next year for the council to
have a look at it and then we have to go
through the decision making process so
that's a big big big job on top of
our ltp budget briefings as well um
i attended the lgnz zone five and six
conference which obviously saw us
visit some of us disappearing down south
on the last board meeting
um really interesting to hear from other
councils
everyone's facing the same issues uh
water is top of mind
and we've got a new president of lgnz
stuart crosby and a new chief executive
susan
freeman green really good to see there's
a lot more diversity
in local government we've got 40 women
more maori more younger elected members
and community boards are contributing to
that as well so well done
um and they're looking at trying to
for lgbt to try and fill the gap and
stop reform being done by
accident to us and that for us to be
more involved at the coal face with
with um department of internal affairs
and so on so that the new team
are trying to really be in the room as
the policy is being made rather than
just
receiving it like we have been doing
quite a bit so that was a really
interesting talk
um the other things we've had at the
council meeting
obviously look robbie's mentions have
already a lot of work being done there
we also have the visitor marketing
strategy which some of you attended
adopted and the draft adopted at the
council meeting which is really focusing
on local market
so making a point of difference is why
come to waimaku area why come here
and getting new zealanders to come to
realise the amazing things
and the key focus of it is actually a
lot of our residents don't even know
the great places we've got in our
district so we have to educate them
to be an educator in new zealand
so we've also had an ips's w advisory
group
mental health continues to be probably
the biggest
challenge um
and we had a visit from the big boss of
civil defence
susan stewart black named norm
and there's a lot of changes happening
in the sort of fence space to make it
more regional
which will help us overall as well
otherwise we've had
other people will talk about the sports
center awards the team esports and
schools
arohati tiala they're starting to talk
to stakeholders but that's mainly out of
our water cinema
um area and obviously we have the
community services awards
she's already mentioned thank you okay
morris
just just a couple of things um
i've been working with jason and jim on
our um submission
for um opposing the quarry by targets
we've had two meetings on that
another thing that i found very
interesting was the rewards last night
that's the first time i've ever been to
them
um i'd like to congratulate the three
councillors here and join us not
on why you spoke for your citations um
i'm not too sure whether you knew the
person or not but sometimes it can be
a little bit difficult giving a citation
when you don't really know the person
that well um it was the first time i saw
dan with the merrill chains on and i
thought he'd done very well
and i told him that after everything
because everything's been canceled up to
this day so you don't really see too
much but
um very impressed with the war zone well
done um
duncan i also was present at awards
they were very good i think what what
struck me was that the diversity within
our district that is
clearly starting to appear and they were
reflected within the awards
and and if i may mr chairman i don't
very often
comment on previous um board minutes
but um morris reported on the drainage
meeting last meeting
um and while he reported very well i was
also presently meeting
but i i the point i want to make and i
think it's information sharing and i
think it's
full well within the criteria was we had
rape powers they're concerned about
how the drainage work was being done
um and this word wetlands came up and
what has really sparked these people off
is that he can have used
satellite imagery to find wetlands
now they i found one on our place and
they haven't told us yet but i know
uh so that that they but all i can tell
them that i finished this three years
ago so i'm well ahead of their play
but um so they're using technology
and the crunch of what these people were
trying to tell us was that the council
my manchester council
hadn't cleaned their drains yet for 20
years
of course it was a wetland because if
the drain hadn't been cleaned
and we raised this issue some time ago
that there are drains
um they're not being cleaned out on a
periodic thing and if you live in
land between ranger or in car park for
example you can imagine how wet they
will get
the imaging picked us up the waimak
district council now is in the
uneven position as they won't intervene
because it's been declared awakening
i thought might be information
very interesting
yeah right sorry also
i like the record but straight um they
don't seem to like me really but
uh jason has been going to the cass
community center meetings
i believe i was nominated to carry on
i spoke to jason he's happy with what
he's doing and there's no problem for me
so i like the record put straight that
he is the representative from this board
on the website it's still me so okay
okay
kay's made it k is made you know yeah
[Music]
concerned about the fact there's going
to be retirement phillips down there
but i've had to explain to a couple of
them that elderly people
usually go to bed at seven o'clock and
they don't
own zippers with blown exhausts and two
wheelies
down the road but in spite of that one
lady's got a hands on the market so
that's the sort of thing that goes on
the other thing i discovered is this
contaminated rubbish
issue two elderly people mentioned to me
that the council has
given them away and they're a little bit
concerned as elvin people can get
and i investigate and i found out it
wasn't the people that lived in the
house
both of them were under full care for
housekeeping
and nursing and when the nurses of the
housekeepers left they were checking
everything in the other
recycled bin so i had to arrange to get
another bin for the finish but that's
another problem
and the other thing that i had happened
was some of the
two of the people that lived at burnside
complained bitterly
about having to slow down from the
fiesta brook road onwards because they
went through and the council
reduced it to 60 and it's
quite interesting because a lot of them
who live up there and go to work in the
morning no intention of slowing down
i was going down there at 90 the other
morning which i shouldn't think
and there was two other cars behind me
and the bloke of the 333 went down the
outside of us and went straight through
the intersection of reflection without
even stopping
so i mean what do you do about that
robbie's listening
[Music]
that's good monique
um i noticed that there was that there's
a group um or a guy
by the name of mike dixon who's put the
opposition
got the opposition to the quarry
thing going and he had the meeting at
the church
recently public meeting and i noticed
his um
post on neighborly trying to encourage
the public to make a submission
against the quarry so i and i emailed
him because he'd ask for them to just do
written submissions and i said i
understand that it's better to do a
verbal
submission as well so i've con yeah i
contacted him and told him to press
and another post to add um add that in
and also said is that there's a small
group that are trying to get themselves
sort of trying to make a bit of an
impact and um
i mean they were aware that rengar
actually community board have a group
that are
opposing it um or trying to getting a
submission together
and so he was pleased about that and
i've um said that maybe we connect up
somehow
so um i had a word to jim
and he's now got jim's number so you can
give him a call to get some
advice for what's going on from this end
that's really all
thank you sarah
um there's probably one or two of us
that have children at school and i
do talk about schools just a little bit
because that's what i
bring to the table so that's if you're
wondering why i mentioned them that's
why i do
um so i have a daughter at rangara high
and she was part of a wearable arts
night
it was a fabulous competitive event
where i was modeling her outfit
which the reason i mention these things
is
one it's a great event and so that's
my part in mixing with the community
you know so that's why i mention what
goes on with schools and what
parts we we as people that do have
children here
bring to the table also
i've got a son who goes to ashgrove
school and they hit the ishgrove
school gala which was very small this
year
and i suppose they get a little bit
nervous about doing these big events and
then having to cancel them so it was
very small
um but nonetheless they still did that
and um
they've got a new principal i think his
name's leon if i've got that right
and he was wandering around and so we
got to meet um
and i'm quite pleased with him actually
the dealings i've had with him in a very
short space of time that he's been there
um he's lovely
so that's a little bit with schools um
on friday the 30th of october yes i did
attend the event at the north canterbury
sport and recreation trust put on at the
main power oval
and a great afternoon of drunks nibbles
and presentations
and announcements where we surprise
surprise found out that the stadium
would be called main power stadium
so that was a lovely lovely afternoon
um sunday the 1st of november
i took a group of women on an 8
kilometer walk starting the silver
stream
and we we started at the urban revival
cafe i took them all the way to kaiboy
looping back to
silverstream again where we all had
coffee at urban revival
and another reason why i mentioned these
things it's a little bit with what
kirsten was saying before
we've got a lot of people who live in
our district who don't even know
where things are they don't know that
they can have coffee at bourbon revival
and walk all the way to kai point but
there's a track that goes right round
the river in eight kilometers
and it's it's just a fantastic
asset that we have that a lot of women
said well i would never even know this
which he was here
i don't charge anything for it because i
think there's a lot of people with no
money
um also kirsten mentioned mental health
i think is
one of the main reasons a lot of people
come along just have a break
it doesn't cost anything they get to see
where things are in our district
and i do take great pride in being able
to take these women on these walks
and that's why i mentioned them um
monday the 2nd of november i was part of
a quiz team that
we had a quiz night at cbk and kaiboy
and that was a local fundraiser for and
we raised money for
kids can and also the
community awards night last night was
brilliant um
thank you to whoever it is that gave us
the invitation we've not been before as
community board members for whatever
reason and it doesn't matter
but i think was very good for us to be a
part of it and see
who actually was the recipients
and the stories behind why they got
those awards
and um i really really enjoyed it so
thank you
jason um firstly because i'm going to
start with the cuss community center my
apologies duncan
didn't mean to stand on any toes um it
seems to be producing quite well over
there
very passionate committee and they
definitely know what they want
so i'm quite looking forward to spending
a few more times down there and
seeing it progress as it goes i attended
the second
north canterbury neighborhood support
governance workshop
because they're trying to take the a new
direction and give it clear guidance for
all its volunteers to really
i guess enhance the neighborliness of
our whole entire region
and community awards
i just want to make a note that i was
incredibly humbled and know that i've
got a very long way to go
to even try and stack up with some of
those applicants
um so congratulations to everyone there
[Music]
[Laughter]
he's hoping um so yeah that was quite a
cool experience and i really appreciate
the invitation
um and i've got a spiel on about this
sorry about the siren but we are
currently doing fundraising for the fire
brigade so if anyone would like a raffle
ticket please let me know and i can sort
you out
thanks jason pooh yeah like robbie we've
had a lot of meetings and what have you
and i'd imagine
murray robbie will have your thing in
the mail tomorrow
um but anyway um we've had lots of
meetings um
if probably most you've probably heard
the cast water supply we've found some
e-coli on it and um luckily for the
council
it sort of proves out the fact while
we're upgrading that system but
unfortunately that system's going to be
um um probably 12 months before it's
finished so
the cast scheme looks like it's going to
have to have chlorine in it
on a permanent basis now so everybody
might be going to get a bit of
flack on that but um that doesn't come
from the council that comes from the
health um the side of it so they get
dictated to the council what happens so
it looks like it's a because it because
it's had the second
um a contamination in a 12 month period
that's
um it's going to have chlorine in it
basically um
forever unless we can find out good
reasons to bring it out if we can find
the
source of the um the contamination
um the mir myself and
jared cleary went and saw her and every
council about the
um the hirani water scheme because as
a lot of people here realize they keep
going into restriction when they
the flow and the ashley river um
drops the hiranui council is quite
concerned about it because
even though it drops here they're still
coming from a bore
and there's actually plenty of water and
it's and it's
they're not even using half of the
resource consent for their
water so um jared come up with a
a reasonably good idea as if um
hironu can connect the uh leaf field
supply
into the um um the ashley supply at the
same time when they go into restrictions
and um we've had communication with the
hanoi council that he can uh
quite um respectful that's
happening so it looks like um if that
happens we may not have a um
restricted on the hiranui scheme and
whether they'll actually use that water
from the lit fuel we don't know
leithfield
i don't know but um it looks quite
promising on that scheme there
anyway um we've had some
bit of bad news i feel from um
the water authority um
in the uh plans from i think don't quote
me on this thing
first july next year it looks like all
our water supplies might have to be
chlorinated
um that's what they're pushing so
our staff are not quite certain whether
we have to have them chlorinated on the
first of july
and then we can apply for an exemption
or whether we're allowed to apply for an
exemption for good reasons to try to
keep chlorine out of
some of our supplies but um when you
read the
scenario it doesn't look good so um so
maybe possibly by the first of july
we may be forced into a um chlorine in
all our water supplies but um
i know uh council water guys um
are going to try to get an exemption
from it but
at the way it's written we don't know
whether we can apply
after we the first of july
after we've got chloride in it or
whether we can do it beforehand so
they're working on that
i'd imagine paul the city will be
feeling strongly about
exactly the same and selwyn as well so
there's
the problem is we're the only three
councils in the whole of new zealand
without the chlorine so we're
sitting all by ourselves which is the
the biggest problem um and i didn't
realize that i thought um
you know um yeah anyway
um i had a meeting with a cycon that the
new
everybody realized cyclone's got a new
roading contract here
um the cycon team have put an extra
truck in for doing potholes now so
there's going to be two trucks rather
than one
and the ceo from the cycon would
um believe it or not he said he'd
appreciate it if
we find any potholes snap solve send
because uh even though they've got
people out looking for these
potholes and fixing them they um find
it's a it's a maze of all the roads
we've got around so
if you see a pothole they've got an
extra truck on board now so please step
side and solve
um the um pothole to them and uh
me when i say they'd like that as well
um
i went to the road safety meeting um
the police have been doing a bit of
thing getting quite a few people with
texting on phones at the moment around
the community um
so it's that's actually quite bad but
the numbers um
uh um well i think they're getting a bit
of revenue out of a wee bit of it but um
um so we have to you know it's quite a
bad thing that's happening around the
area uh
you know um there's three policemen at
the meeting one of the senior ones and
it was worse than what they expected it
to be
so um so that's a bit of a worry what's
happening
um
that's probably about all for now
thank you cool andy
um nothing particular about meetings but
um
just of interest in ashley logan north
lobland is um
i mean the roads are still really bad
hopefully cyclone gets a better grader
driver
but um there's a lot of burglaries going
on on lifestyle blocks at the moment
and um a lot of anxious people um
lots of um security cameras and things
are getting installed
it's really bad is it in houses or just
out lifestyle blocks sheds motorbikes
you know
getting stolen and yeah it's uh i think
i think there's a group of two or three
guys that steal a vehicle
go out to um you know logan north loburn
and then um in the early hours of the
morning and rip them off but um
yeah it's tough to they're struggling to
get them at the moment apparently
quite concerning thank you andy item 11
consultation
projects you've just been emailed in the
last
short while ravenswood that's just gone
out that closes on the 14th
of december and it's for you that's for
your board funding for your information
landscape for your information
items 13 14 and 15 nothing
there so that brings us to the end of
our
formal formal meeting the next meeting
as you would see is on wednesday the 9th
so
we're now moving to clear close and
we'll move into workshop
i notice the